I think that they ask you a series of
questions that I've already to this same
function okay
and it's a bit weird because you we're
sort of quiet comfortable most people
are with dealing with what happens where
you slap absolute ghost notes around a
number that's all okay and then when he
gets the functions you're supposed to
mean okay so rewind a little bit you'll
see me doing this quite often because
it's the best place to go to to wrap
your head around like all the concepts
related absent value which is what is
the definition of absolute value there
are a few definitions but the most
helpful one is always this one and if
you haven't got it maybe we're gonna
shut down well so you should definitely
have this in like your first page
absolute value a is shorthand for two
different things sometimes the absolute
value of a is just a provided as
positive okay so yeah absolute value 5
is just 5 the absolute value 87 is just
a 7 but if a is not positive if it's
negative then we slap another negative
sign on it and that cancels out so the
absolute value is negative 5 is negative
maybe 5 and that's what turns it into
positive 1 okay now this one's for
numbers this is the definition for now
it's the same deal with functions okay
so when you can't have a look at this I
can say this absolute value of x I can
replace that either with X or with
negative x depending on where it is or
what its value is
okay so I can replace that this guy down
here he doesn't care about this up and
down thing he's always the same thing so
when I write this and say okay it's
gonna be this or this the first case is
this if X is positive
so I've literally just replaced this
with this just like I have here or
alternatively it's gonna be this if X is
negative now I will just put out there's
a big problem with this particularly for
this example here which is that if X is
equal to 0 the whole thing explodes
right because you kind of like ideas
know it by the way like why is it that
we say the technical words undefined why
is it we say you can't divide by 0
because there why cuz it just it just
doesn't make sense
I'll tell you why because that
multiplying by zero is fine adding 0 is
fine subtracting 0 is 5 what's the
problem with division divisions are
equal in the inverse function so we
understand what division is based on
what multiplication is so for example we
could say 6 divided by 2 is 3 right but
the reason we can say that it is because
6 is equal to 3 times 2 like that's
actually where it comes from
right now therefore you can see the
problem with if you're dividing by 0 so
suppose you have some number like say 5
and you divide it by 0 okay and you're
like I don't know what that's equal to I
wonder what should be what value I
should assign to it well let's just call
that value X I don't know what it is but
if you apply the same logic that
division has to get its meaning from
multiplication then if you multiply both
sides by 0 then that tells you yeah
exactly you like oh well that should be
x times 0 but no no there's no X that
you can put in there that will make that
work because anything multiplied by 0 of
course is 0 so that's why you can't
actually into fine there's no way you
can do that there's no nobody would ever
make sense so therefore we say you can't
divide by 0 so that's why here if X is
positive things work if X is negative
things work and if x is 0 you're stuffed
okay which is why if I if I go back to
something else
you know if I asked us to graph this
right the picture of this we have a nave
in this function what's it called the
SATs of an age it's a hyperbola right so
roughly speaking yeah so this is like
the rough shape okay but we know that
it's not that it just keeps on going
like that they actually never gets there
so that's why we draw these dotted lines
these asymptotes right so this has some
time here that goes up and down it's x
equals zero horizontally you can't go
there to kill ago right so you can never
get there for the same reason that you
can't divide by zero so when you look at
this this can't work at x equals zero so
I could say it's undefined this is part
a I think it's undefined at x equals
zero
okay and generally speaking if you've
got anything any function divided by any
other function right this whole thing y
equals this it will be undefined
wherever that bottom thing is zero right
so wherever whatever that function is is
zero so let me give you you know 1 over
x squared minus 1 that's going to be
undefined at two places because the
denominator is zero at 2 places namely
plus and minus 1 right how about this do
you remember the reciprocal functions
from RC do you remember being introduced
to their names
yeah so I'm with the three reciprocal
functions are SEC cosec and cot right I
don't know if you guys have ever seen
this before but there's a really cheap
and someone could it's it into a way to
remember which ones which
yeah and it's right so if you just write
down the three reciprocal functions
there they are just have a look at the
third that up that's somewhat coincident
talk about the west so now this is there
for Cusack X and it's undefined an
infinite number of places because sine X
like do you guys remember this is a
while back down when you met the sign
causative functions they they wave
around like this ok
in fact that's why the sign is called
sine sine comes from the Latin word for
like sinus which is which means curved
and we call it curved because that's the
shape of the graph now you can see here
and here and here and here and here and
on for infinity sine X is going to be
equal to 0 every time sine x is 0 1 over
sine X is undefined
ok so you get this graph with an
infinite number of vertical asymptotes
of it ok so now when we come back yeah
this it's relatively simple it's only
equal to 0 the denominator it is totally
comma zero once so that's the only place
that I've deployed is that ok all right
now once you establish that the absolute
value signs around the way so I should
do something cute right so you can see X
over X is just 1 and negative x over X
is just yeah very good and of course I'm
not including any like equality like
that because I'm just distance yeah
explain why so therefore I'll take that
out now ready to draw a thing so on a
set of axes with strange let's go from
left to right this is on the Left X is
less than 0 so everywhere that X is less
than 0 that's all of these parts over
here the graph is y equals negative 1
well that's just a horizontal line like
that so I'm just going to label
as well maybe 40 now what that x equals
zero
what's happening there the answer is
nothing is happening there you can't say
I'm here or there or anywhere so that's
why we put an open circle like that so
we say x equals zero doesn't have any
value and then you cross over to the
right hand side when X is positive it's
going to be one anything exactly the
same way is undefined there so there's a
hole itself and that we think is the
graph it's strange but if you follow
through the definition of what absolute
value is it just kind of falls up and
that's all it can be all right so how do
you feel with that is that okay so much
a good okay so let's have a look at 12
and it does take off a bit okay so the
owner of you can see that foot should be
yeah so foot 11 beads is using table the
table of values for X so change in your
eyes yeah yep see goes for you there
just cancel out doesn't make a walk
correct sir these Acme rights so huh I
suppose what I've done is I've gone
straight to here right but if I didn't
do this if I just came back to over here
just right on the first line right and
said okay X Y and then I pick some
values
so you can see what's going to happen is
alright for this it's going to be the
absolute value of negative three on
three
that's why a name like that that's the
absolute value of X 1 X and that's what
X is right so that's going to be 3 on
negative 3 well that's you know you've
won okay and then here you have to know
your video to on negative 2 that's to
who I'm there you to which again is
negative 1 and you're going to keep on
getting negative 1 for any of these
values until here when you're like sorry
it shops closed
ok then over here you say I'm the
absolute value of x on X which is 1 over
1 which is what and it keeps on going
all the way
so generating a stable values is kind of
just checking have I done the right
thing you have I simplified this
correctly and it confirms that we did ok